[Music]
truly like no [ __ ] who do you think
really benefits from this book and what
stood out
in the book writing process of this one
for you did it flow easily were you more
challenged than you thought what is your
favorite
social media platform right now for you
the human being
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
[Music]
podcast nation what is good uh it is so
nice to be recording an original podcast
uh
thank you all so much for listening to
the show every day
and uh i'm incredibly excited as you
know these days i'm just not doing a
whole lot of interviews but
incredibly excited for today's guest uh
because she's been an inspiration for so
many of my friends
uh and fellow entrepreneurs over the
last
20 years and i've had the luxury of
interacting with her
here and there and she's got a new book
and one of the funniest things is
you know i write more books than i read
them but uh
but i know how many people because i
write them so often
how many people learn from them love
them and it's really truly one of my
favorite platforms
of expression and information and and
i i love to really you know it's funny
i don't read the books or the galleys i
i read
and believe in the people that i put on
uh and
the feedback of all the authors that
we've put on over the last
year and a half has been overwhelming so
here's another one
uh rebecca minkoff is an entrepreneur to
me
i'll let her jump in and explain who she
is to all of you right now in her words
and then we're gonna get into the book
uh current events and thematics around
the book so rebecca thanks for being on
the show
gary i'm so excited the last time we
were together pre-pandemic
we were talking about buying your wine
and how good it was
and then the world ended so i'm glad to
see you've been leading the world
very well since then thank you thank you
so much
tell everybody a little bit about who
you are what how do you describe your
bio in
in three minutes you know it's funny i
was transitioning more into
like you introduced me founder obviously
now best-selling author
um and the president of my company was
like you are a designer to these women
stop talking about being a founder and
entrepreneur they want to know that you
are a designer and i was like okay
i will re-add that to my my list of
things that i am
she's like when people are buying a 300
bag they want to know that you designed
it which i do
but i i like i was proud of identifying
as more than that and now she's like
own it babe this is what got you here
yeah yeah and by the way
because it's both right i'm uh you know
i'm a
you know sometimes people like he's a
speaker and i'm like ugh
but i'm like but i am and and a wine
person
and an operator so to your point because
you are you're both
and more correct and uh just got to
embrace that too now
um what uh when you think of being a
designer
or an entrepreneur and an author what
are the
what do you think has gotten you here
and when i say here
you've had success you have good
relationships you have a good reputation
like if i asked you like what's gotten
you quote-unquote here
uh what do you think that is and then
we'll and then i want to segue into the
book
yes grit relationships
and asking for help asking for what you
need i should say not asking for help i
think the grit
comes in because you know this it's hard
no matter what business you're in
you're gonna get punched in the face
more times than you care to admit
and you need to just get back up like
those dolls that you punch and get back
up
like and then relationships you know
before you go there before you go there
dig into each of them yeah so do you
humbly which is the third one by the way
we'll get to that in a second
humbly do you do you feel like you were
gifted the dna
and and your circumstance of your
childhood have put you in a position
where you have really good tenacity
yeah but i don't think i was born with
it i think i was
raised with it in my household no one
got what they wanted unless
they earned it and you know the simplest
things
you know we're told no unless you made
the money for it and so
growing up i had to know how to figure
you know [ __ ] out and i had to know how
to earn money and get what i wanted
because it wasn't
your parents your parents weren't into
spoiling
no definitely the opposite and and you
and you see that as like a remarkable
gift in hindsight right
yes and i'm trying to raise my kids with
it it's not working
not because i'm not doing it because
they don't even care but
i really cared i wanted that thing bad
enough that i was really willing to work
for it am i getting like
meaning your children are so not
materialistic and want things
or thank god to the luxuries of your
life because i'm dealing with this
they have enough by collateral of their
realities
that they don't need they don't really
like it's okay they like
because that's what i'm struggling i
don't feel like my kids or other kids
that are in a
better financial place than i was as a
kid it's not that it's a spoilage it's
just even their normality is so much
greater than what i had
that it's different right it's a mixture
of both their normality which is not
excessive it's not what you read about
with these hundred thousand dollar bar
mitzvahs and you know we're not we're
not living this
lavish life but i think what they have
they don't have to want for
a lot but anytime they want something
outside of you know
food and a birthday present and a
hanukkah gift it's like well you're
gonna earn it and they're like eh
i'd rather not and they just go about
their life and i'm like how do i inspire
you to get grit
you know it's it's tough to you know
it's tough to fake environment right
like i went on two family vacations
my entire childhood right like even if i
don't excessively do things
my kids went on two in their first year
of life right
exactly you know it's just different
yeah um okay so
tenacity i'm a huge buyer tenacity and
grit
uh relationships is where you were going
next
yep so i am here because of women and
men who saw something
and i s and they they saw a spark of
something and then when i asked
because again you know i meet so many
people and i was guilty of this
waiting for someone to say gosh you seem
talented
i'd like to do this for you like that
never happens the cavalry is not coming
so they saw a spark or they were excited
and then i had to ask which
a lot of times was uncomfortable you
know um but a lot of the people who got
me to where
i got to is because i asked them for
that i said can you help me do this one
thing or can you get me on this
magazine or on this tv show or on the
celebrity or whatever it was that got me
here now and so
i think did that come natural to you or
did
you know i would argue that that is an
incredibly difficult thing for me
you know um it's a it's
asking for something is not a strength
of mine yeah
uh and i don't and i don't think it's
ego or well it's
got to be ego and pride in some ways but
it was so foreign in my
household you know i never saw my
parents
ever ever ask for anything of anybody
and it just became
subconscious reality but i i want to be
better at it
i don't struggle with humility because i
don't think i'm [ __ ]
but i do struggle with asking did that
come natural to you
or or was that developed i think it came
natural
because i feel like i got to new york i
was not making nearly enough money to
survive on my own
and the only way i could get ahead
was to ask people you know my friend do
you have any styling jobs for me i'll
prove myself or
to the website the one website did you
i'm sorry i actually want to hear that
the one website go ahead
the one website that existed i sold my
goods to i'd be like hey can you advance
me
the money because otherwise i can't buy
the goods like i'm not making any money
here so
you pay me for the orders in advance and
i'll go fund this this little company
um i think it was just out of there was
nothing there was no cushion so i had to
ask
did um uh that just sounds like good
negotiations by the way
more so than asking you know um
why'd you come to new york i came to new
york because going back to my parents
and the lack of
what we were given for hanukkah we would
have choices like you can have
one magazine subscription or you could
have an alarm clock i chose the magazine
subscription
and i would get my vogues or my harper's
bazaar or whatever and i was just like
oh my god what an incredibly beautiful
world
that new york city is through the
magazines and that's where fashion is it
was either paris or new york and i
didn't feel quite ready to go to a place
where i didn't speak the language and i
was like that's where it has to be
i love that i'm sorry where did you grow
up
i grew up in san diego great weather
great weather right like crazy like it
freaks me out every time i'm there i'm
like
i wanna you know as the world is now
going remote and more and more i'm like
man
i think san diego is a real shot of
exploding over the next 30 years
yeah it's going to have you know it's
kind of gone downhill a little bit
but i had the most idyllic childhood
there like
yes it's amazing um and uh
and the third one i i transferred in my
head is humility but what did you say
asking for what you need got it yeah
it's one of this
right you used relationships to kind of
touch it cool what's the book
the book is called fearless the new
rules for unlocking creativity courage
and success and as i looked back on
i can't believe i say this 20 years of
being in this business
um breaking a lot of rules because again
i was not deemed by anna wintour
the the darling designer um i really
came
from the outside and so the rules that i
had to reinvent
um that got me here i wanted to write
down because i feel like
other entrepreneurs or entrepreneurs can
benefit
from these rules they're basic there's
nothing
you know so groundbreakingly deep but
people forget about them
and it's simple stuff that as you're
going along
remember these things and when you're
struggling you're like should i take a
risk i'm scared
because again people let fear stop them
so i wanted these rules so that you had
sort of guideposts that when you're
scared to take risk or do something nuts
you you don't not have the fear you just
proceed anyway
[Music]
what stood out in the book writing
process of this one for you did it flow
easily were you more challenged than you
thought did you remember [ __ ] that you
completely forgot about
do you feel one part of it really excels
versus another
yeah so i had the opportunity to have a
friend
sit me down for four days and interview
me and draw out things i'd forgotten
in a way that we would you know like
what you said um
and so that was extraordinarily helpful
to be able to then
pick and choose okay this is a book
that's supposed to help people it's not
my autobiography so what stories am i
going to tell you
that matter and that will teach you a
lesson that was hard to sort of pick
apart
i think the chapter that resonates with
me the most was
i've talked about it a lot but last year
you know 70 percent of our business
evaporated
um overnight and we had to rebuild our
company and so as i'm sitting there
writing a book about how to get started
i sort of had to
get down and cozy with reapplying those
same rules to succeed
and so that was that chat the final
chapter was kind of you know the the
publisher was like
please don't write about the pandemic
plea we want this to be an evergreen
book and i'm like but it's pretty
central to what i'm going through right
now
yeah so yeah i i i never i never write
evergreen books
weirdly i actually just did it's coming
out in november it's my
probably only my second evergreen book
the thank you economy
was but the thank you economy had a ton
of contextual
things going on at the time i think i
think
i think publishers don't realize that
the context of the current
actually helps books more than the one
in one million evergreen book that gets
printed seven hundred thousand editions
totally and it needed it needed it to
frame this book because i went back to
my rules and i tested them as i rebuilt
my company and they worked so
yeah i mean you know it's funny i think
a lot of us i mean
i i i 100 am most proud
of my last 14 months there besides what
i did
at the day after 9 11 for my young
business my dad's business at the time
except for that
six months i've never been more proud
of you know being an operator than i've
been the last 14 months i mean talk
about
being in such a curious position and to
be here 14 months later in such a
power position um i really thought that
this was a chapter where
operators and take out a couple of
industries like restaurants and others
where you really
in certain scenarios or like events
businesses because restaurants adjusted
because they had delivery but
can you hear me yeah yeah yeah yep i
think a lot of
opera a lot of us went back to our roots
these last 18 months and it sounds like
you did as well you had to because
all of a sudden why would a woman need a
handbag right now she wasn't going
anywhere
so how to navigate that slippery slope
was quite challenging but we did it we
emerged
stronger and uh 10 up over the year
prior so
it was definitely through through a lot
of grit tenacity
relationships you know and asking for
what i needed for sure
what um who do you think really gets
like truly like no [ __ ] like not
like a today show interview like on some
real [ __ ] because i know you'll give it
to me
when you now see the book because you
know i had an idea
for the my book and now i'm seeing it
it's done and i'm like oh okay
it kind of tweaked and went little left
a little right a little this way
who do you think really benefits from
this book and why
like i'm sure there's a lot of people
because fearlessness i mean
fear is the [ __ ] poison of society so
i love your title because i hate fear
[ __ ] hate it um and especially when
people
weaponize it and everybody and so many
people do um
but you know like before we talk about
the
second or third or fourth group that
will really get a lot out of this
if i if i asked you which is not like an
author's favorite thing to do but i'm
asking you
go very narrow to the group that you
think this really crushes for is there
anything that stands out
yeah and it was someone's else's
perspective
that made me go oh my god maybe there's
a layer to this that i didn't even
realize i was doing
i think there has been um
this girl boss culture of i
look perfect i act perfect i'm strong
and
i'm a girl who's a boss and i think
my book is more about like this [ __ ] is
hard
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] up here's 21
different nightmares that i've gone
through
to then learn this rule or lesson and so
i think it's for the person who's like
that didn't ever seem real to me like
she had it all
and i'm not just talking about one
person but these feminine icons that
have been put up
on this bar and never talked about the
struggle
in a in a more in a meaningful way or
they talked about the struggle as they
were hitting rock bottom but never on
the way up
and so i think it's for that person
who's on the way up who needs the truth
and who's like oh i got to click buttons
my whole life to get my car
and my amazon and i thought my career
would be this way and i'm like news
flash
it's not and you better be prepared to
work
yeah i love it good for you what do you
think where do you think it uh
what are the some of the satellite
groups of people that you think will
work for
i think anyone who is fearful uh whether
it's again
should i quit should i start a company
should i raise money you know
fear which protects us from bears and
scary men in the woods
uh shouldn't be an emotion that is used
that we use to stop us in life from
succeeding and so while i would never
say my book is a self-help book and
you're definitely not going to finish
the book and say
i'm fearless it just means that you're
like yeah i'm scared and what here i go
right it's it's it's getting a
relationship with fear and letting it
sit with you
instead of demonizing it or [ __ ] or
letting it [ __ ] you
correct i like that uh
what's your fear uh
of the books because you're competitive
i
am scary i really am i know you are it's
so funny
i i that was just such a bad job as an
interviewer i just
i've had you know we haven't had the
most interactions
but we've had enough where that just
came so easy to me because it's one of
my favorite things about you
it's really interesting i'm at the time
in my life where i think i have to start
really
digging into competitiveness because i
think it's in a very interesting place
in society
i don't talk about it at all a lot it's
obvious
it comes through but it's not a big
pillar of my content but i want it to be
because it's such a factor yeah but i
haven't really gone
in my own self with like the healthy and
unhealthy parts of my competitiveness
and why it works
um but i love that about you it's like
literally my word cloud for you like
literally like when i
i like i dm'd you the other day about
something else that i want you to come
to
and like literally i was just going
through like a b like my followers i was
like
i've got a very small group to this
thing who do i want to invite it was
like that random it like
had nothing to do with the fact that we
were doing the podcast today that wasn't
why it was on my mind i was just
literally going through it
and it was funny what my brain did
literally i
said to myself i love that she's so
competitive and that was just like a
random thought
now i just brought it up again in a
podcast so i'm really excited about this
because i think this is
the most [ __ ] from my author friends
and authors that i know
like i laugh because all of them no
matter
you know it's never about the money for
a lot of people
that have had a good career in writing a
book for authors it is it's their money
maker but
it's just a competitiveness of how well
the book will do
and i couldn't wait to ask you and i'm
glad i got it i was worried i was
worried i was gonna forget and i didn't
so i'm pumped
like how how did that how does that feel
how's it going
like like what were you like like some
real talk which i think would really
help people like it's not beating this
other book
i can think i can't remember the names
but i always knew like the book that
like
was doing better than my book every time
they were out that i'd be like [ __ ] and
you know like
like like how do you how are you dealing
with the competitive nature of this and
like
tell everybody like how the process was
and is around this book for you
competitively
yes so i was entering a whole new space
developing an entirely new audience and
so that was
that it was a six-month full-time job
birthing this book
and um i'm very proud
of it and the sales that we've hit and
sales we continue to hit
and it's as i mentioned a bestseller but
you have certain things that you know
someone was like you can't really be
complaining about this please stop
uh you know i wanted to hit certain
lists that i didn't and i can't for the
life of me understand why
um there's such hard and there's wrapped
up in that
there's you know like it didn't you know
i know i'm still affecting women's lives
because i'm getting these incredible
letters i quit my job because i read
your book i
you know i'm gonna you know demand a
promotion because i read your book and
i'm
and i love that and then i'm still like
damn it i didn't make
the new york times bestseller list and i
know i sold enough books
that's the problem right is i know i
sold
week one you know over ten thousand
books so and i know that
other people on the list sold six so i
have no rhyme or reason and i
and because they might and i'm in it
because it eats away at me
yeah because they because they do a mix
right like
what is bulk what is not which sources
it's like nielsen ratings they're not
real what is real
is the fact that your book came out on
june 15th
we're we're taping this on the 20th i
assume this podcast will be out within
seven days
the fact that you're over a month in and
amazon's data is incredibly real and the
fact that you're at 2500 in the world
right that it's the 2500 2589 right this
second number two in fashion textile
number six in women in business like
number 103 in the world on personal
finance
you know a lot of books fall off a cliff
after the first week or two when i see
that and
i know you enough to know you're not on
tv
every day you don't have the biggest
podcast in the world every day
you're you're not pumping out 50 pieces
of creative on social media every day
when i see those numbers and i've been
in this for now 13
years i know that
you've got word of mouth going that
the book yeah i can tell you from an
outside perspective
and very honestly like i i love you and
i cheer for you but i have no horse in
this race i can give a [ __ ]
i know that it if it's doing those
numbers right now on amazon at this
exact second i just looked
that knowing your promotion cycle and
like your platforms
i'm like oh [ __ ] that must be a really
good book because
the only way it's doing those numbers
right now is that there's word of mouth
going on
nice well that's that's very i trust you
because i know you know your [ __ ]
so that's good to hear and what uh who
was
the most fun person you hadn't talked to
in a while
that reached out to you because of the
book whether
it was because of the business marketing
strategy beforehand
or after the book came out or even more
fun
because they read it and wanted to say
something to you my
high school english teacher amazing
yeah she is the one that quit her job
she said i read your book i was a
principal out of school and i said i
just want to be a teacher and i quit and
i start my new job
you know september and i was like
hallelujah man
that's so cool that like i took english
from you i took creative writing from
you and you just reached out after you
read my book and you quit your job
because of it
my english teacher saw me at the javits
center when i was doing a book
uh event for my second book
and it was mrs horobat big shout out
came up to me there was
like hundreds of people crowding selfies
all this and i was so good to see her
and i gave her a big hug and i said miss
horvath
could you have ever imagined me having
this
book when i failed all your classes and
she went into
no no no you weren't that bad i'm like
miss hormat it's amazing how history
rewrites itself
but um but that's really neat made me
think of that story so
what uh as we're wrapping up what um
what do you want people to know about
this book
why should they get it or what other
things should we touch on before we get
out of here
i think we should touch on the fact that
you know i offer
with my brand you know clothing that is
supposed to make a woman feel confident
fearless um optimistic
and i was like oh [ __ ] when she reads
this book she can now also embody that
mindset
you know and so i think it's the
complementary
second part of the woman you know and
the world that we create with the brand
have you seen any pictures with somebody
having your book sticking out of
your handbag not yet i've seen a lot of
people posting pictures on vacation with
a really beautiful drink
and they're sitting by the pool by the
way you'll never believe this one of the
reasons i
historically have liked to release books
around spring break in the summer is i
want
instagram photos with hot dog legs and
my book
like i literally think like that like i
literally this one's close to my
birthday but
i real in winter but like i've always
wanted to do summer in spring books i've
pushed for that in the past because
i've i love that photo i don't know why
but it's just such a nice photo
totally all right vaynernation do me a
favor if you know if you've got
uh one of rebecca's incredible handbags
buy the book stick it in there get on
social
tag me and rebecca i want to share it i
think she deserves that photo it's a
good feeling
um i have an offer for vaynernation if
you want
oh sure what do you got if you buy the
book
anywhere books are sold and you email me
the receipt i'll give you 25 bucks
off my website anything you order so
you're basically getting the book
i like this hustle i like this hustle
all right what's your name what's your
email fearless
rebecca minkoff.com just put
vaynernation in the subject line
with your video so cool say one more
time i love this right hook this is one
of my moves
um fearless rebecca makeoff.com send me
a screenshot and your address of your
receipt of wherever you want to buy your
book
audio kindle whatever and i and i'll
send you a 25 gift card
i like this is there anything that they
can buy for 25 bucks on your site or
will be or
too expensive they could apply no yeah
they could so what's the what's the
lowest thing
95 bucks
for like 65 so if you got to spend 20
extra bucks
yeah yeah uh like some fun
lightning round what is your favorite
social media platform right now for you
the human being like using or consuming
however you want to take that question
um
i guess i'm dating myself but still
instagram i still
you know i'm i'm excited i think that's
sad that
we're moving on from picture to video
but it still entertains me
i actually think it's the biggest
opportunity i've literally
been haven't been able to get this out
of my mind that if i wasn't so goddamn
busy
i would start a social network that is
picture only
yeah just to take you know because the
opportunity has now arisen
right it's true you can put it on that
phone
what about netflix hulu
hbo max what are you binging um
on hulu handmaid's tale on netflix i
just
finished the walking dead i was a couple
of years behind
i just watched the queen's gambit i'm
also i'm a little bit behind on all
these things because
there's three kids but yes
um and final final final thought what
are you most excited about
uh post summer i'm excited
post summer about we have two three new
brand category launches
so i'm excited about those babies to be
born and you're gonna be really proud of
me for our fashion week activation i
can't talk about it here but it's
definitely something you're going to be
let me know i'm proud of you listen i i
what i'm what i'm really excited about
is
that i was able to give you this
platform and i know a lot of people just
discovered you
uh and i'm glad about that and so i
highly recommend
please vaynernation don't do the cliche
[ __ ] when i tell you
i know this entrepreneur uh this is not
a female girl boss book every dude
[ __ ] listening to this will get
tremendous value because i read every
[ __ ] dm
and dudes are just as [ __ ] scared
about [ __ ]
and you know and so please don't let's
do that cliche
[ __ ] please check out the book please
understand this entrepreneur
uh and and designer and human
and i'm really glad we got to do this
podcast thank you gary
so what uh as we're wrapping up what um
what do you want people to know about
this book why should they get it or
what other things should we touch on
before we get out of here
i think we should touch on the fact that
you know i offer
with my brand you know clothing that is
supposed to make a woman feel confident
fearless um optimistic
and i was like oh [ __ ] when she reads
this book she can now also embody that
mindset
you know and so i think it's the
complementary
second part of the woman you know and
the world that we create with the brand
have you seen any pictures with somebody
having your book sticking out of
your handbag not yet i've seen a lot of
people
posting pictures on vacation with a
really beautiful drink
and they're sitting by the pool by the
way you'll never believe this one of the
reasons i
historically have liked to release books
around spring break in the summer is i
want
instagram photos with hot dog legs and
my book
like i literally think like that like i
literally this one's close to my
birthday but
i real in winter but like i've always
wanted to do summer and spring books i
pushed for that in the past because
i've i love that photo i don't know why
but it's just such a nice photo
totally all right vaynernation do me a
favor if it you know if you've got uh
one of rebecca's incredible handbags
buy the book stick it in there get on
social tag me and rebecca i want to
share it
i think she deserves that photo it's a
good feeling
i have an offer for vaynernation if you
want oh sure what do you got
if you buy the book anywhere books are
sold and you email me the receipt
i'll give you 25 bucks off my website
anything you order
so you're basically getting the books i
like this hustle i like this hustle
all right what's your name what's your
email fearless rebeccaminkoff.com
just put vaynernation in the subject
line with your video so cool
say one more time i love this right hook
this is one of my moves
um fearless rebeccamakeoff.com send me a
screenshot and your address of your
receipt of wherever you want to buy your
book
audio kindle whatever and i and i'll
send you a 25 gift card
i like this is there anything that they
can buy for 25 bucks on your site or
will be or things too expensive they
could apply no
yeah they could so what's the what's the
lowest thing 95 bucks
i think we have some earrings for like
65 so if you got to spend 20 extra bucks
yeah yeah uh like some fun
lightning round what is your favorite
social media platform right now for you
the human being like using or consuming
however you want to take that question
um
i guess i'm dating myself but still
instagram i still
you know i'm i'm excited i think that's
dating
we're moving on from picture to video
but it still entertains me
i actually think it's the biggest
opportunity i've literally
been haven't been able to get this out
of my mind that if i wasn't so goddamn
busy
i would start a social network that is
picture only
yeah just to take you know because the
opportunity has now arisen
right it's true you can put on that
phone
what about netflix hulu
hbo max what are you binging um
on hulu handmaid's tale on netflix i
just
finished the walking dead i was a couple
of years behind
i just watched the queen's gambit i'm
also i'm a little bit behind on all
these things because
the hashtag three kids but yes
um and final final final thought
what are you most excited about uh post
summer
i'm excited post summer about we have
two
three new brand category launches so i'm
excited about those babies to be born
and you're going to be really proud of
me for our fashion week activation i
can't talk about it here but it's
definitely something you're going to be
let me know i'm proud of you listen i i
what i'm what i'm really excited about
is
that i was able to give you this
platform and i know a lot of people just
discovered you
uh and i'm glad about that and so i
highly recommend
please vaynernation don't do the cliche
[ __ ] when i tell you
i know this entrepreneur uh this is not
a female girl boss book every dude
[ __ ] listening to this will get
tremendous value because i read every
[ __ ] dm and dudes are just as [ __ ]
scared
about [ __ ] and you know and so please
don't let's do that cliche chip please
check out the book
please understand this entrepreneur uh
and
and designer and human and i'm really
glad we got to do this podcast
thank you gary youtube
what's up it's garyvee first of all
thank you so much i hope you're doing
super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon